you are genuinely fan of the books and
the game and everything apparently on
set you know more than anyone else I
wouldn't necessarily say anyone else but
I I am
yes I'm a big fan yeah so do you correct
people
um I don't necessarily
I am effusive about getting the uh being
being loyal to the source material let's
put it that way okay so yes yes you do
you do fly your nerd flag with pride
what now one of your hobbies and he's
got a lot of them ladies and gentlemen
one of your hobbies is you paint makes
you sound weird
I have more Hobbies than the average man
I'd say but you you paint is it war of
World of Warcraft uh Warhammer Warhammer
I'm a fool
it's more Hammer gray okay
so what you see you you paint by hand
yes yeah does everyone do that or can
you buy them or no you have to paint
them but it's just how much effort you
put into it there's a lot of everything
there's the painting modeling side of
the Hobby and then there's the gaming
side Lobby okay and when you paint them
what do you do with them then Henry then
you um put them together in real armies
and you fight against someone else's
Army
God it's actually it is fun oh man it
sounds ridiculous but it is yeah no toys
very good fun
A lot's been made about uh Superman's
disguise
as Clark Kent yeah
really light it is it's it's a very
light disguise seemingly so really like
I've got the glasses so if you just pop
them on so we can see the difference
that the glasses make just pass them
down
there we go
prepared to be amazed
oh what where's Henry gone
that's really creepy crazy
it's even creepy when you say it in that
voice
because it is one of those things it's
amazing that either they haven't come up
with some sort of backstory or like you
kind of think in 2016 they wouldn't just
put you in some glasses and say and no
one will know who you are
but actually didn't you do an experiment
I didn't indeed yeah to be a
Counterpoint to what you're talking
about yeah to prove you wrong in fact
um we were a friend of mine and I were
discussing the idea of these glasses not
being good enough disguise and uh we
decided to go to Times Square to test
the theory I wore a Superman t-shirt and
no glasses and stood underneath the
giant wrap around Batman v Superman
posters in Times Square I think we've
got we've got a picture over there there
you are yeah
and took a bunch of other photos and
some video as well and uh got stopped
twice
once by someone exiting a Subway asking
for directions to Central Station
and the other time I was in a coffee
shop where someone said could you please
stop taking photos
that was it that is bizarre yeah yeah
it's it's apparently very easy to do can
you take you just
look really comfortable in those classes
yeah oh for once
but now uh you know for all these roles
you have to be an amazing shape so the
witch are the same where you just have
to kind of shred shred shred yes
um the training for these kind of things
the most important thing is is your own
health it's so you can stay physically
fit without injuries while doing all
these these crazy things like being
thrown against pillars jumping out of
um airplanes it's uh it that's what it
really is for I mean yes you're supposed
to look a certain way aesthetically
especially getting a shirt off but
um it's mostly for just just staying
healthy but the weird thing is and this
doesn't add very healthy if you're doing
one of those shirt things
um you can't shoot less shirtless if
you're doing a shirtless scene what's
that you have to dehydrate yourself oh
yeah yeah that is by that's the worst
part of it like Diet is difficult um and
you're hungry but when you're
dehydrating for three days you get to
the point on the last day where you can
smell water like nearby so why why did
you do that to get soup it gets your uh
it makes your skin really thin so it
sits on the muscles
um yeah you've got a scene with your top
off because Bryn came out to the Sea and
Gavin and Stacy I did not dehydrate for
three days
before I do
yes yes I was in good shape yeah so so
you did and then it makes it up oh yeah
yeah but for three days that can't be
good it's not it's not no water for
three days on the first day you'll have
um like a liter and a half and the
second day half a liter and then the
third day no water and you'll shoot the
fourth and the funeral is on the sixth
day
a lot of times sometimes they don't
shoot the scene till the end of the
fourth day as well and so you're the
most miserable person on the planet
sure we were looking at at the top of
the show there yeah you posted it you
posted that picture and fairness if I
looked like that I'd be sitting with my
top off right now
now you posted on Facebook didn't you uh
oh yes Facebook and Instagram yeah
somebody did and uh well the comments
the comments were that's actually from
my Facebook page
it's your it's your goal I was going to
do worse than that only less than that
yeah do not exceed this
yeah the the comments on Facebook though
I love that people like bother to put
these things I think I just wet my
panties
this next person I have the weirdest
boner right now
we're hoping that's a man I wonder what
was weird about it I know
at this one I just love this one this is
just holy sweet little seven pound baby
Jesus
happy Easter I don't know
and Henry you know Henry huge star now
but there was a bit in your career where
you kind of were going to give up
weren't you oh yeah yeah
last week
that's today
um I yes there was it just I think early
on in my career I got the cattle Monte
Cristo and then a couple of movies after
that and and then I was auditioning I
was always aiming for leading roles yeah
and getting all the right things were
being said to me um afterwards by by the
casting directors and saying you were
great the best person walked in the room
but you're not a name and we need a name
and so that was a thing and I thought
well this feels a bit like a catch-22
scenario and I became a little bit
disenchanted with the whole thing and I
thought well you know what I'm going to
give it a little bit more time and then
I'm going to follow my original course
which was go join the armed forces and
it was then that I got the bond screen
test
and that was the thing which put me in
variety and then my name was in variety
and then more people started pursuing me
and it became a bit more I was not a
name as such but I had at least been
printed in variety also the fact that
you got so close I mean made you kind of
a player I guess people were I mean if I
guess if they were interested then there
was a chance that yeah I had something
oh Henry I don't know if you know this
but uh the bond position is vacant
[Laughter]
that's why you're wearing glasses
I mean I have to ask you are you in the
running if you put yourself out of the
running if they came a calling would you
say Yes
um I I would definitely have a
conversation I think there's lunch lunch
yeah
from what I from what I understand
there's there's very very early
conversations happening up top at MGM
and and with Barbara and Mike but uh
there's no list as such yet so I I
there's no list top I was like there's
no you know that
internet
Googled it yeah right Henry Cavill James
Bond
in Hollywood everyone's auditioning
um or in the acting industry everyone's
trying to get a role and they're not
necessarily getting them and so to get
an opportunity to be in the Limelight by
missing out on the big roles is actually
a good thing as opposed to a bad thing
and I I count my lucky stars for each
one of those okay you're turning it into
a positive it still sounds quite to
just lose jobs attack no didn't get it
again that's great but it's great for my
profile I'm the guy who never works
because it wasn't Twilight written for
you oh well hey I don't know I wouldn't
go that far
or you can
I I think the writer of the books when
the movie came around I think I was her
first choice I think that's the rumor I
heard and she wanted me to play the role
but
it wasn't up to her and instead you know
a very talented active played instead
wow
[Laughter]
who will remain nameless
not that he's angry
wealthy and famous for the nameless
in Twilight all the Twilights he's in
there being the remake
Henry you're probably not going to miss
your face Furniture you're not fond of
the face Furniture are you oh it's not
that I'm not fond of it it's just that
you know if I'm if I'm walking past
schools people give me funny looks
it's tough to buy Vans
I won't give children sweeties
do you normally do that alone
[Laughter]
[Applause]
very few men can carry that off but no
it's very good do you know what that's
annoying about that it's that's like if
Henry Cavill wore a stupid hat you would
think oh that stupid hat looks really
good
and it's not just he looks really good
and you put it on it's a stupid hat yeah
what was your nickname at school uh my
nickname in school was fat Cavill
uh considering my name was indeed Cavill
and I was indeed fat
how lordy were you
um I mean I I my dad always said from
the age of about 13 I stayed the same
weight until I was 25 I just got taller
okay so you were enormously fat at 13.
um I I don't know about enormously fat
you were more videos you could have died
um
but now the odd thing about kind of this
movie is uh that Russell you you met fat
Cavill
yeah he he definitely wasn't fat cattle
when I met him at 16 no no but we were
shooting here in London a movie called
Proof of Life in 2000 and uh there was
the opening sequence of the film was
shot at Stowe
College you know and um we went out
there and there was a kid there called
Merlin Hanbury Tennyson who was playing
my son and uh
in a break of the shooting you know
which was actually there was a rugby
union game going on and there was one
kid on that field who was very fluid and
in control so I actually caught my eye
and I was watching and that kid
that was fluid and in control came over
to have a chat but all his questions
were about acting you know and there was
just a smile in his eyes where there was
something dead serious behind that smile
so instead of uh not answering the
questions or whatever because you get
asked these questions 100 000 times
I told him the truth
you know in the brief moment that I had
with him and um
put it in front of him that you know
it's a challenge that's up to him you
know
uh nobody's going to give it to you
a couple of days later I was put into
package together for the kid who played
my son because I figured the greatest
thing if you're at boarding school must
be unexpected mail right you know yeah
so and I thought I'll put one together
for that other bloke and I remembered
his name because he'd been very clear
when he said he didn't say hi I'm fat
cattle but he did say hi
Superman
[Music]
actually because I had two of the same
photographs and for the one that I wrote
for Merlin I put on a you come from a
long line of generals there's a
photograph from Gladiator
he went and joined the army three tours
of Afghanistan later and now he does
close personal security here in London
wow
um and on Henry's I put a journey of a
Thousand Miles begins with a single step
basically you know if you want it you go
and get it you know
12 years later and it was probably three
months into working together you know I
finally said to him do I know you from
somewhere
and you got this little smile on his
eyes he went
do you remember going to snow School
I guess do you remember a kid that came
and talked about acting all right
yeah yes trust me I said really what did
I say
and he said well um you said they pay
you pretty well but they treat you like
I said yes
foreign
[Music]